karl oder nicht kann ja das ist die
wichtige frage heute im politischen
berlin karl lauterbach wird er nun
gesundheitsminister oder etwa nicht die
einen ihnen den panikmacher die anderen
nennen ihn den corona experten und olaf
scholz er wusste lange nicht aber in
kürze will er sich endlich festlegen er
will die carl frage beantworten und was
macht karl lauterbach bis dahin da der
sitzt in einer talkshow also am abend
war bei anne will
was also gesundheitsminister kann ich
nicht sprechen weil das nicht feststeht
da hat die spd eine reihe von leuten das
gut machen könnten und da wird es morgen
zu entscheidungen kommt hat
urlaubsländern angerufen oder shorts
also hat also mich in vielerlei hinsicht
also sagen wir abgeordneten
wissenschaftler angerufen aber in dieser
sache sind die entscheidungen noch nicht
gefallen da bitte ich um verständnis und
also da kann ich nur sagen dass schon
häufiger gesagt habe ich bin froh dass
der spd dieses wichtige ressort gezogen
hat wie man es heute sagt also das wird
von der spd besetzt aber dort gibt es
wirklich gute leute die das können und
von daher bin ich sicher dass das gut
besetzt sein wird darf ich mal was dazu
sagen als jemand aus dem
gesundheitswesen also ich kenne ganz
viele kollegen inklusive mir herr
lauterbach wir würden uns sehr freuen
wenn sie unser zukünftiger
gesundheitsminister würden weil wir
einfach auch mal sagen jemand vom fach
ein arzt der das tut und ich kann da nur
sagen ich appelliere noch mal wenn der
anruf noch nicht geschehen ist dass man
doch mal ganz gut drüber nachdenkt weil
es gibt keinen der das so ausführen
könnten wir sie auch kompetente
mannschaft dafür bedanke ich mich ja
dafür bedankt er sich fühlt sich
geschmeichelt wir wollen karl sagt diese
krankenschwester diese sanitäterin aber
es gibt eben auch ganz viele im land die
das auf keinen fall wollen an diesem tag
karl oder nicht karl das ist tatsächlich
heute die frage in deutschland die gehts
weiter mit dem mann der das land so
stark polarisiert hat wie wenig andere
in diesem corona ja darüber sprechen wir
jetzt hier im studio mit bild
chefreporter peter tiede und der hat
hoffentlich schon die nachricht oder
etwa nicht peter karl oder nicht kann
immer noch ein geheimnis klar wirklich
ja also ich gehe mal davon aus also ich
bin bereit ein schokoladen besen zu
fressen live im studio
wenn er so wird ich glaube nicht daran
karl lauterbach kann auch nicht sagen
dass er angerufen worden ist in egal ob
als minister oder nicht als minister und
wir brauchen im herzen corinna minister
also karl lauterbach hat sich sehr
exponiert karl lauterbach ist einer der
experten in ancona pandemie aber ich
sage mal es gibt in der partei nicht
durchsetzbar und wurde auch nicht prolog
noch einmal im chancen barometer wie
viel prozent jetzt eine knappe stunde
bevor olaf scholz das bekannt gibt wie
für prozent sprechen für karl lauterbach
wie viel prozent dagegen ich bin kein
wahrsager ich leg mich da nicht fest ich
sage nur ich fresse als schokoladen
diesen wenn das wird zu laden
also ich das gelesen aus schokolade
woanders liegen darunter auch als lernte
tischler also die k frage ist eher
geklärt wo das scholz und kanzler und
carlotta aber in meinen augen wird er
nicht gesund ist aber ich wieder und
brauch ich fest wir haben auch schon
sind im gesundheitswesen auch schon die
berühmten pferde vor der apotheke
frau
und sie ist mit dieser spd also
sein kann aber wir müssen ganz ganz klar
sagen heute ist der tag an dem wissen
wir wer uns künftig regieren wird heute
werden wir das gesamte kabinett wir
wissen ja schon wieder von den grünen
und wer von der fdp ins kabinett zieht
ins erste kabinett olaf scholz und
sogenannter kabinett scholz 1 das wissen
wir wir wissen dass olaf scholz kanzler
wird wir wissen wer ist ein
kanzleramtschef wird mir ahnen wir
innenministerin wird das wird vor
lamprecht wer bisher die
justizministerin wir ahnen dass sogar
das heil weiter das arbeitsministerium
machen wird ich würde mal sagen dass
zumindest in die nähe des kabinettstisch
wenn nicht sogar direkt daran vielleicht
sogar klara geywitz kommt das ist die
frau aus potsdam die spd frau die mit
olaf scholz zusammen damals das buch
gebildet hat alles lässt sich
das nicht schafft als er spd-chef werden
wollte und die spd in mehrheitlich
abgelehnt hat ich glaube man dass klara
geywitz auch eine versierte frau eine
gute politikerin die in potsdam kenne
dass die in die nähe des kommunistisch
kommt vielleicht sogar rand also dass
wir in der spd durchfallen die können
dann immer noch im schnee
da ist klara geywitz ist ja wirklich ein
anderes kaliber klara geywitz ist in der
spd auch in brandenburg mal etwas nicht
geworden weil es etwas gestanden hat und
klagen
ich kenne sie wirklich lange und gut
dass ich nicht drauf kommen erst noch
einmal über karl lauterbach sprechen
auch wenn du nicht glaubst dass es wird
wie ist nun überhaupt sein standing in
der partei gerade so wie in der
gesellschaft auch als völlig zerrissen
die einen lieben ihn und die anderen
schütteln graf ja aber die mehrheit in
der spd martin das überhaupt gar keine
keine frage es gibt auch in die starke
strömung gegen ihn es gibt auch unter
gesundheitspolitikern welche die hinter
kritisieren die auch ein bisschen
neidisch auf die medien aufmerksamkeit
die ihr natürlich auf sich zieht und
doch auf sich gezogen hat und da ist die
spd die andere partei der herrschen auch
international versucht jetzt hat er
sicher offenbar dachte gerade beim
anschauen des ausschnittes von anne will
hat sich schon die minister frisur
eigentlich zurechtgelegt war schon ein
bisschen anders gestylt als in den
letzten monaten als in der gesamten
corona krise nachdem er ja erst mal
seine flieger abgelegt hatte jetzt also
neue frisur bei karl lauterbach bessere
styling aber einmal um noch mal auf
seine rolle zu sprechen zu kommen was
patricia gerade schon gesagt hat
entscheidend ist ja wie sich der olaf
scholz positioniert für karl oder gegen
karl du sagst wahrscheinlich gegen karl
das wird er aber erklären müssen der
olaf scholz der hat eine ganze community
eine ganze karl fällen community an der
backe der heute erklären muss warum er
nicht karl lauterbach gewählt hat als
gesundheitsminister wie soll da das
machen aber vielleicht wird kein auto
macht ja nicht gesundheitsminister und
vielleicht wird kann auch da war so eine
art corona minister es gibt ja den
krisenstab und vielleicht wird carsten
weiß nicht ob das ein post posten für
karl lauterbach ist auch vor der
pandemie egal denn nicht zwingend als
ministrabel haben gutes verhältnis zu
ihm wir können uns offen mit offenem
visier sachen sagen und ich schätze
manchmal auch sein rad und auch wirklich
dass ein vertrauenswürdiger mensch
ist er minister habe ich weiß es nicht
also jemand der so eigenständig ist und
auch so eine type ist wie ihr karl
lauterbach kann auch schnell mal zum
querschläger werden wenn du da politisch
eingreifen willst als kanzler wenn du
dann mal tatsächlich von der nahe
richtigen kompetenz gebrauch machen wird
es kann ja passieren das kann aber
gesagt weil er anderer meinung ist weiß
ich nicht es gibt genügend andere gute
gesundheitsexperten in der spd ich weiß
nicht ob es ist so viele gute krone
experten in der spd geht das darüber
muss man reden aber ich glaube dass oder
sonst eine lösung findet was er sich
nicht leisten kann ist da jetzt führend
jemanden zu versorgen also irgend jemand
zu holen der mal an apotheker vor so hat
er auch schon mal beim arzt war da muss
jetzt schon auch eingestand
gesundheitspolitiker hin da darf jetzt
nicht proporz kommen nur weil
irgendjemand von irgendwo was deutsche
frau also nur ostdeutsche frau ist und
meine apotheke war darf man jetzt nicht
gesundheitsminister wenn das dach wo das
nicht passiert und ich glaube auch nicht
dass es passieren wird das hatten wir
mit spannung ab mal sehen ob du nachher
schokoladen besen frist und wo wir den
eigentlich auftreiben das war doch sie
erwarten natürlich auch was wir
allerdings wissen ist das ist extrem
machtkampf gab gestern hinter den
kulissen und das zum beispiel rolf
mützenich der der spd-fraktionschef
eigentlich unbedingt unbedingt minister
für entwicklungshilfe für entwicklung
werden wollte und dass es da wohl
heftigen streit gab und dass es sein
kann dass rolf mützenich vielleicht
einfach spd-fraktionschef weiter machen
musst gegen seinen willen okay aber
alles guckt heute auch klar und alles
möchte wissen hat jetzt olaf scholz ihn
am abend noch angerufen vielleicht nach
der anne will sendung lässt er ihn doch
zumindest werden die antwort ich komme
aus kapieren um gut 50 minuten hierbei
bild live dann nämlich stand olaf scholz
nach langem überlegen nach langem
nachdenken nach einem spd parteitag dann
heute auch endlich seine minister und
ministerinnen hier in berlin vor und
bild live ist dabei